الى قصبه حيث قال رئيس الوزراء قالبين
كورتي ان المقترح الاوروبيه للتواصل الى
اتفاق المعاصر بها يتضمن عناصر تضمن
الاستقرار وظيفا انا بالجراد لم تقدم اي
اشارات بانها مستعده للقبول به واكد كورتي
ان حكوماته لم تقدم اي تنازلات المقابله
ازاله الحواجز التي نصبها نشيطونها من
الاقليه الصربيه في شماليه البلاد وضح
كورتي ان قوات حفظ السلام التي يقوده
النيت كانت قد طلبت قبل نهايه العام
الماضي مهله لازاله الحواجز وان حكومته
منحت هذه القوات ما طلبته وامتنعت عن
تدخلي شرطتك
المزيد معنا من ميتروفيتش شماليه كوسبوه
مراسلنا محمد المدهون محمد اهلا بك في ظل
هذه التجاربات المستمره بين بروشتنا وبيل
جراد ما الذي استقر عليه الوضع في شمالك
والصبوحه
كبير الاوضاع الميدانيه هدات بعد ان تمكنت
قوه حفظ السلام التي يقودها حلف شمال
الاطلسي من ازاله اخر الحواجز التي كان
نصبها ناشطون سرب خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
بين البلدان والقرى والمدن هنا في شمالي
كسب وانا موجود في بلده متروبيتسا نقف على
الجسر الرئيسي الذي يفصل هذه البلده الى
جزئين جزء الالباني خلف الكاميرا الجزء
اللي همم الاغلبيه المسلمه تعيش هناك
والجزء الخلفي هنا هو الجزء السر
لاغلبيه
تحيي هذا المساء وبعد ساعات من الان عاشيه
عيد الميلاد بحسب التقويم الارثوذكسي
ولابد ان هذه المناسبه دفعت همم طبعا همم
المجتمعين المحليين هنا الى تهدئه الاوضاع
قليلا ولكن التوترات قد تعود في اي وقت
هذا ثابت يؤمن به الجميع
سياسي الى ايطالي ملن يثبت هذا الهدوء
ويننهي اي امكانيه لعوده همم تلك التوترات
التي شهدتها البلاد خلال الاشهر السته
الماضيه وتكثفت خلال تحديدا الاسابيع
الاخيره من شهر ديسمبر بسبب قضايا عديده
حقيقه من يعيش هنا في هذا الحي خلفي هم
كما ذكرنا من السرب الذين يدينون بالولاء
بلغراد رغم ان هذه المنطقه تقع ضمن اراضي
كوسوفو والاراضي التي تعتبرها كسوف جزءا
منها ولها السياده عليها وتطالب وحدتها مع
كامل الاراضي كسوف وتحدث اليوم رئيس
الوزراء الكوسوفي عن هذا المقترح الفرنسيه
الالمانيه الذي يطرح منذ اشهر ويريد ان
همم يكرر التجربه الالمانيه ما بين
المانيا الشرقيه والمانيا الغربيه خلال
القرن الماضي حيث كان هناك تطبيق في
العلاقات ما بين البلدين دون اعترافا
متبادلا بينهما
المدهون كنت معنا من مترو فيتسا شماليه
بكلغ وشكرا جزيلا لك